alrighty welcome in just one second
we're going to be analyzing a wonderful
hanukkah video it's hanukkah it's time
to analyze a deeply
meaningful spiritual video about the
meaning of hanukkah from
kamala harris and her husband douglas
imhof by the way
this video is sponsored by ring and this
is a video of douglas emhoff and kamala
harris talking about hanukkah and the
meaning of hanukkah now
let's just be straight about this
hanukkah has been watered down by the
american jewish community into basically
nothingness
it's basically supposed to be low rent
christmas you light up some lights
everybody's happy you sing some songs
about a dreidel and then you give some
presents that is not what hanukkah is
about at all i mean if you actually read
the history of hanukkah like read the
books of maccabees for example
and it is about a bloody war between
jews who wish to practice their religion
free of the hellenizing influence of
greece and a group of hellenized jews
who wish to act in concert with the
greeks to shut down
religious practice in other words in
many ways it is a battle between
religion
and paganism and secularism that is
that's kind of what hanukkah comes down
to the fact that that has somehow been
you know wrapped up into a ball by
american sources
into well basically it's just about you
light up some lights and it's about
social just
it's not any of these things okay so
there is something that democrats like
to do when it comes to
various members of the intersectional
community and that is they find
one of their friends who's a member of
the intersectional community and then
they bring him forth to show that they
have special solidarity with that
community
so there are not a lot of high-profile
people in the biden team who are jewish
really not not a lot and so kamala
harris's husband
happens to be ethnically jewish i don't
think that he's religiously jewish and
the reason i say i don't think that he's
religiously jewish be
like in any serious sense like beyond
maybe going to shoal once a year or
something
is because one of the chief tenets of
religious judaism is that you're
supposed to marry
other jews so i assume that he did not
keep that because kamala harris is in
jewish it's a free country you can do
whatever you want but if we are now
talking about jewish religious practice
jewish religious practice has certain
dictats those are not followed by
douglas emhoff so i wouldn't take him as
like your authoritative source
on what judaism thinks but in order to
promote the idea of solidarity with the
jewish community
they put out this video and listen i'm
fine with solidarity you want to do that
that's fine but
if we are talking about like the true
meaning of hanukkah versus a
watered-down ridiculous miscongeniality
version of hanukkah which is what you're
about to say
at a certain point i'm out so here is
this video
in which douglas emma questions his wife
kamala harris
about her views on hanukkah which again
that is like me questioning my wife
in a jew born in israel about her views
on christmas i don't know what special
authority kamala harris has to talk
about hanukkah
at all at all as someone who frequently
relies on my wife's expertise for
medical
care and advice i actually ask her what
she thinks like really really this
should be about kamala harris asking
douglas zemhoff what he thinks of
hanukkah if you're even going to do this
stupid video in the first place
that's not what happens here's douglas
emhoff questioning kamala harris about
the meaning of chanukah to her which
like
what all right here we go hey everybody
we're here to talk about one of our
favorite
holidays in our big modern family
hanukkah
and why do you love hanukkah i love
hanukkah because
it really is about
the light light where there has been
dark
sweet and there is so much work to be
done in the world
to bring light and it is a celebration
of
always tikkun oh god okay stop this crap
for a second stop it stop it stop it
okay stop it okay so first of all
she's struggling with this answer in the
same way that she struggled with the
answer why did you call joe biden a
racist and then run with him
she has no answer to this question and
so she's like lighting mclightlight
mclight light light
you see right here i have a i have a
menorah and uh it's got a candle on it
you know we do it that we lighty
we lighty it it's filled with light and
it brings light with light
it's about bringing light to darkness
okay well actually specifically it's
about
bringing the temple practice back into
practice
right specifically about the fulfillment
of religious duty she ain't going to
talk about that one because that ain't
with the democratic agenda yeah and then
she says that it's about tikkun olam
okay tikkun olam
is this bullcrap nonsense pushed by the
left in which
they reinterpret the phrase tikkun olam
to mean
a bunch of leftist social justice
warrior nonsense
comes from this kabbalistic idea that
god shattered the unity of the universe
when he created the universe and then he
restricted himself and it is our job
to help put back the vessel together but
the way in judaism that you do that is
by following the commandments
the notion of tikkun alam is not about
some broad social justice agenda
it's about you following particular
commandments 613 of them
in order to rectify the breaches that
were created
when god created the universe because
god created the possibility of human sin
he created the possibility of human
freedom and human choice and that comes
complete with the capacity
to help destroy the universe through
your own sin so instead what tikkun alam
originally was about in jewish
philosophy was the basic notion that you
were
you were going to make the world a
better place through the performance of
the mitzvot also worth noting
tikkun alam is not considered a central
part
of jewish philosophy until very late in
jewish philosophy
like namely the 20th century before like
if you look at orthodox judaism
orthodox judaism where we actually you
know go to synagogue several times a day
and we practice 613 commandments or try
to like tikkun alam is not a central
part of what we talk about
ever right we always talk about
following the commandments what's the
best way to practice the commandments
what are the values of the torah
tikkun alam is essentially a a
left-wing attempt to grab onto a
kabbalistic concept
and then ram that kabbalistic concept
into it's a square peg ram it into the
round hole of social justice warrior
nonsense so that's why she's happy with
this because this is a rewriting of
judaism into a bunch of leftist claptrap
we're gonna watch more of this cloying
annoying ridiculous video in just one
second but first i gotta tell you about
our sponsors over at ring it is indeed
doorbell season the busiest time of the
year at your front door that is
definitely true
at my house we are receiving all sorts
of packages and deliveries friends and
family are stopping by dropping things
off
with ring you can keep an eye on all of
this hustle and bustle no matter where
you are directly from your phone
if somebody stops by something's going
on ring lets you know you can see and
speak to whoever
is there from anywhere this holiday
season it's not just the best time to
have ring
it's also the best time to give it ring
makes an excellent holiday gift so this
holiday season gives somebody the gift
of peace of mind ring has security
products for every corner of your home
inside and out
best of all you can see it all in the
ring app i use ring to keep track of my
three kids they're always running around
there's one of me three of them the only
way i can keep track of them
is with the ring devices in my home ring
has everything you need to keep an eye
on your home this holiday season and
throughout the year
see and speak to whomever is at your
door from anywhere with video doorbells
keep an eye on every corner of your
house with easy to install indoor and
outdoor cams help protect your whole
home with ring alarm a powerful
affordable whole home security system
you can easily install yourself for a
limited time
head on over to ring.com ben for special
holiday offers that is ring.com
ben so apparently hanukkah is about like
gay marriage and abortion or something
here's kamala harris
fighting for justice and and fighting
for
the dignity of all people and it's about
rededication
and it's about joy and it's about god
it's about spreading joy
around the world and sharing it with
your family and your friends and your
neighbors
and your community that's important
right now so that's what we are doing
is to wish everyone a happy hanukkah
and to your family from ours
we wish you all the best that is an
enthusiastic handle yeah let's do it
okay okay
now she's excited she's got something to
do we're gonna light a candle here light
a candle for tikkun olam
salad stuff right there wow
amazing amazing and then they light a
candle to biden harris transition
it's about joy i love when he has to
like pipe in right there he's like and
it's about joy too it's also about joy
again if you want to ignore the entire
message of the holiday then go with this
it's about so what we learned in this
video from kamala harris is that
hanukkah a holiday that i actually
celebrate and know about because
again i'm an orthodox jew apparently it
is about
several things it is about lighting make
light light make light light light
light light and also it is about joy
enjoys your joy also we get together and
it's joyful so basically
it's like you know like thanksgiving but
not really because thanksgiving
had bad white people in it so like it's
another holiday like
i don't know it's basically like kwanzaa
it's like well it's not kwanzaa
right it's not it's not like kwanzaa
really because it's because it's got
jews in it so
it's it's more like it's more like no
that's got some jesus in it
it's more like it's more like earth day
it's like earth day right without the
composting of the of the creator's
girlfriend but more like earth day
like of all the things it's like earth
day right it's completing the world
and joy and light and happiness so all
that stuff comes later it's about an
actual bloody civil war
in 198 bc antiochus iii of the seleucid
empire took control of the jewish
homeland of israel
it was then called judea he promised the
jews they would not have to hand over
control of their religious observance to
the greeks
they would not be forcibly hellenized
hellenized just means essentially
greekified
nevertheless a lot of jews decided to
imbibe greek religion when antiochus iii
died his son antiochus iv
took over he immediately tossed out the
jewish high priest who's named oneis
that guy was opposed to hellenization
replaced him with jason who was a
loyalist to the seleucid empire jason
had bribed the king to get him to make
that move
jason then murdered while removing
judaism as the religion of the city and
that was just
the beginning so you heard kamala talk
about all the light light joy joy joy
the actual reason the jews light the
candles is because jewish tradition says
that when the temple services were
reinstituted there was not enough oil
for the menorah one day's worth of oil
lasted for eight hence the eight days of
hanukkah but that followed again a
bloody civil war
in which jewish loyalists were the
maccabees were fighting back not just
against the seleucid empire but also
against hellenized jews who wish to
crack down
on jewish observance so as much more
about the establishment of national
sovereignty
it was much more about religious
observance and freedom to worship
it was much more about this harsh civil
war than it was about these
vague bizarre notions of tikkun alam and
joy and light and getting together
and then we're nice to each other that's
that's not what the holidays about and
it's about
rededication and it's about joy it's
about rededication
to god i love that she just leaves that
out there it's like rededication
rededication well it's rededication of
the temple
what did they do in the temple did they
perform abortions no they did not
in the temple they rededicated
themselves to the temple service which
was about rededication to god
and the mitzvot right it was about the
re-inculcation
of jewish practice in israel
by the way at point of sword and so this
is the anodyne watered-down version of
hanukkah brought to you by people who
really are not super fond of religious
practice and religious worship
and this is kind of what so many folks
on the left actually want religion to be
what they want religion to be
is basically the way they think of
recycling right recycling is just
virtuous it's good in and of itself
doesn't matter if it does anything
but it's got like some ritual attached
to it and it's nice for the world right
it's got
joy and light and rededication and fun
and tikkun olam
okay that is not what any real religious
holiday is about in any mainstream
religion that i'm aware of and if you
can boil down a holiday to joy
and light and you can't even explain
what the holiday is especially a holiday
that is
as harsh as hanukkah like the fact that
people think that hanukkah is like happy
dappy do is
beyond me it's just crazy again even the
part
of the hanukkah service that is about
lighting the candles
in the temple okay the part about the
miracle of the oil
that comes about that story comes about
in the talmud that is hundreds of years
after the actual events of hanukkah
hanukkah was originally meant to
commemorate the victorious
maccabees and the establishment of the
hasmonean dynasty after the expulsion
of the seleucids right so that like it
actually has real world
consequences a very practical hard-nosed
holiday
but i just love that it has become for
for secularists light and joy and miss
congeniality and what's your favorite
day my favorite day is in april it's
just perfect for a light sweater
that's that's what it comes down to so
thank you for that meaningful
tribute to my religion that i take
rather seriously
people who do not take my religion
particularly seriously if you actually
want to hear what hanukkah is
actually about i did an entire video on
this a couple of years ago we put the
link in the description below click on
that you can see the whole story there
it's not kamala harris's story alrighty
we'll see you here next time and happy
hanukkah
and light a candle in favor of religious
observance do that in honor of hanukkah